One of the things I've learned from
studying that the mythological worldview,
first of all,
I think the mythological worldview
conceptualizes the world as a place to act
rather than as a place of state.
So it's sort of like Steven g Jay Gould's
idea of two magistarium don't overlap.
There's a moral magistarium
materialists magistarium say,
but it's been striking to me looking
at the archetypical foundations of
mythological thinking that in
that in the scientific world view,
there seem to be two
fundamental causal elements.
You could say nature and nurture,
something like that or
biology and society.
And then technically sophisticated
western academics argue about the relative
contribution of each to any given,
uh,
existential phenomena.
But in the mythological worldview,
there's always three actors.
Here's nature,
um,
usually personified as female
or experienced as female.
Cause personified isn't
quite the right word.
There's culture,
but there's also the individual and the
individual seems to be the same thing as
the conscious actor.
And that would be the hero of
the dragon slaying hero say.
And there's that,
there is a kind of primacy given to that.
And so in the oldest creation myths,
you always see this interplay
between the the mother,
often mother earth and the father that
the sky and then the hero who separates
the two and somehow brains
and perversely in some sense,
although being their product clearly
as the offspring is also the thing that
gives rise to them at the
same at the same time.
And it seems to be something that's in
keeping in some sense with our lived
experience is that we confront the social
world obviously and our beneficiaries
and victims of it.
And we confront the natural
world in the same manner.
But we also seem to be a gigantic actors
and without us as a genetic actors,
the idea that there is a reality seems to,
it seems to be full of paradoxical holes
like reality without a conscious actor.
And I think that's the sort of thing
that generates the thinking that you've
referred to as characteristic of of
Deepak Chopra and the people who,
who make those sorts of claims.
So,
I mean,
what's your,
what's your take on,
on consciousness and its role in being
well and the one,
and it's everything because,
um,
it,
it's what I tell what I tell deep,
like what I write about
in that chapter is that,
um,
you're,
you're familiar with
the anthropic principle.
So I call this the,
that the week consciousness
principle that,
um,
without consciousness,
nothing exists.
You know,
this is one of the points to buck makes,
uh,
and for me and you personally,
if we're dead or we're not conscious,
the world doesn't exist for our brains.
It's gone.
Nothing.
There's nothing.
Uh,
but,
but he goes further than that.
He says this is what I call the
strong consciousness principle.
That that consciousness is required.
Our consciousness is required
for material things to exist.
And so there I have a discussion of what,
um,
uh,
Donald Hoffman,
the cognitive scientists
at UC Irvine Coliseum,
um,
uh,
interface perception theory.
Uh,
I dunno if you're familiar with this,
but his analogy is like,
you know,
your laptop screen here.
Then you'd have these icons on the
screen and like the little trashcan icon
looks like a trashcan.
But of course there's no
trash get the Oakland,
the open your laptop,
there's no pro trashcan in there.
You know,
these are just kind of icons that
represent something that we think of as a
trash can.
And um,
you know,
this is,
gets to the problem of,
you know what it's like to be a bat,
a famous thought experiment.
I can't know if like bolted on some,
some huge ears.
And I,
and I had an echolocation system and
the neural processes to process that
information until on,
I would have some sense of
what it's like to be at that,
but they have everything on
to actually be a bad thing.
And I would just be a bat
and I wouldn't even be a,
wouldn't even know I was a human wondering
what it's like to be a federal case
at some level.
We can't actually know.
Um,
you know what it's like
to be something else.
And so you,
again,
with Deepak and I and these
kinds of traditions like that,
we hit this system,
logical wall of language.
It's difficult to say what
you mean by certain things.
Yes.